MMM.
Hello and welcome to the fourth lesson in native link dot coms introduction to
historical linguistics and language change.
Last time around,
we looked at some basic words in three lift Tineke or romance languages and
determined how they were related to each other.
We also filled out their family tree back in time and saw that they had this
relationship dependent on the existence of some common ancestor that was an
actual language spoken in the past.
We also determined that if we didn't have a tested data for that language,
we'd have to go back and reconstruct the language to know what it was like.
In this lesson,
we're going to do some of those basic reconstructions to determine the shape of
an ancestral language that isn't a tested.
In other words,
we have no written records of it.
We're going to start with some fresh data from an few new languages.
These are all Polynesian languages.
I'll start out by saying they're all related to each other.
We're not trying to determine here if they're related,
but rather what is the common ancestral form that these cognates all share.
These cognates all come from some one word in the past.
What was the shape of that one word?
So here are some words for numbers in these languages.
As you can see,
the forms are all very close.
It's easy to tell based on this data at least that the languages are related.
I've given you the IPA forms,
the international phonetic alphabet forms of these words because we need to look
at sounds and sound change to determine how these words changed.
If you're not familiar with the IPA,
even though this symbols used here a fairly basic,
I have a whole lesson on that.
I'll put a link to it below.
I also need to introduce you to innovations and retentions,
innovations or changes to ancestral forms that were introduced at some point in
the past.
They may occur in one language or they may be shared by a group of more closely
related languages.
Retentions are those forms in this case,
the sounds that go back to the common ancestor.
What we need to do is determine which of the sounds here our retentions and
which are innovation.
Once we can do that,
we can posit common forms that must have occurred in the parent or the
reconstructed language.
One simple innovation shows up pretty quickly as we look at this data.
Notice that Hawaiian always has this prefixed material,
this a in front of every single number.
This shows up only in Hawaiian and not in any of the other languages.
We have good grounds for assuming that this is an innovation.
We don't have hard proof here,
but the common material to all of these numbers does not include that a,
so when we're looking the Hawaiian numbers,
the common material is everything after that a,
so let's compare individual sounds.
Notice the phoneme t,
the voiceless dental plosive that shows up in most languages,
but also noticed this curiosity that some languages instead of having the
phoneme t have this voiceless Vilar stop instead of the voiceless dental stop.
In this case,
there's almost something like a democratic vote by the languages against the
Vilar Plosive,
the k sound being the original phony.
We have a pretty good indication that t was an original phoning,
a retention that changed to the innovation.
K It has specific language in Hawaii,
so we choose t as the ancestral inherited retained phoneme in all of these
languages.
That then changed to a k in some instances,
but it would be lazy of us to stop there.
We should go and confirm against further data.
What we'd find is that this is indeed the case where there's a k and Hawaiian
other cognates in other languages have a tea and vice versa where there's a t in
the other languages there's a k and Hawaiian,
so this seems to be confirmed across the board.
We can posit some tea in the ancestral language.
What's more,
we're not surprised to find that the number seven has a form with tea and not
with a k in that ancestral language and so our reconstruction of that root is
pretty straightforward.
The question becomes a bit more complicated when we look at ELLs and ours.
Take a look at the word for the number two and four,
the number three and the number eight in the Polynesian languages that we have
here.
Should the reconstructions of these languages have an l or an r?
One thing to notice here is that languages that have an l seemed to always have
an l and languages that have an ar seem to always have an r and there's a good
distribution here,
so which one should we choose?
As I mentioned,
this isn't so straight forward.
What we'll need to do is to extend our comparison to other languages.
These languages aren't as closely related.
They'll give us some comparative evidence for the distribution of ls and rs
throughout the whole family.
You can see in these languages that l and R are distinct phonemes.
In other words,
l doesn't always show up when our does.
What's even more important is that these languages are consistent in their
distribution of Lnr,
so it's a reasonable to suppose that this distinction was also made in the
common ancestor language.
That's the parent of the Polynesian languages we're evaluating based on this
evidence will reconstruct the numbers two and three.
This way
we can then conclude that some of the daughter languages changed all instances
of ELLs and ours too.
Our and other daughter languages changed all instances of ELLs and ours to l.
When it comes to sound change,
there's a lot going on.
There are reasons for seeing typological characteristics.
In other words,
these types of sound changes tend to happen.
These other ones don't or are less common so we have grounds for saying that the
change from the phoneme f to the phoneme h is a common and expected one but we
wouldn't expect h to turn into f and the same goes for V and.
W.
We commonly expect a woman to turn into a like sound.
On top of that there are regular types of sound changes that happened in
languages and these are especially important for understanding language change.
If you'd like to take a look at those types of regular sound changes like
assimilation,
which I believe I've mentioned before in a previous lesson,
to get a more in depth understanding of assimilation dissimilation and things
like metathesis,
compensatory lengthening and so on.
I put together a brief page with definitions and examples.
I'll leave you the URL for that page as well.
I really hope this lesson has been helpful for you.
I know it's a brief introduction,
but take a look at the site,
you'll get more information there and a couple of exercises as well.
Thanks for learning with me.